happy almost st. Patty's Day
are you drinking a green beer and are
you hole in your shell a li hope you're
kissing the Blarney Stone that might
have been racist to Irish people yeah
they're probably too drunk to notice
anyway to honor a great drinking holiday
we're playing TV drinking games The
Honeymooners was the first show with the
drinking game associated with it
Americans would chug a beer every time
the lovable Ralph Kramden threatened his
wife with domestic violence now let's
move on to some modern drinking games
everybody is waiting for Breaking Bad to
come back in honor of Walt's mastery of
chemistry the Breaking Bad for a game is
all about the compounds anytime they
mentioned Heisenberg say my name is chug
ch3 ch2 Oh H + h2o that's beer damn
right if we see that sweet blue meth
then drink ch3 ch2 Oh H + h2o + C 3 7 h
3 4 & 2 & 8 209 s 3 that's beer with
blue food coloring
please don't fact-check it Game of
Thrones everytime Jon Snow gets beaten
up by a girl
emasculate yourself by drinking an
appletini anytime they talk about
dragons drink a flaming shot every time
Dinklage does something awesome honor
that man with a half pint whenever
someone is beheaded drink a chalice full
of the blood of your foes
[Music]
homeland when al-qaeda blow something up
drink an Irish Car Bomb have a whiskey
sour
every time carry does this
[Music]
anytime there's torture getting
waterboarded with beer
[Music]
you want to get drunk while you're
watching HBO's girls sure you do anytime
Lena Dunham shows her booze chug Kahlua
and breast milk every time they complain
about first world problems why you
always eat my yogurt drink dirty
third-world water every time one of the
girls has their period well are you
getting your period you know I'm not
drink the blood of your fallen enemies
I'm sorry that was disgusting
here's one for you real alkies five
nights a week you can drink to Jay Leno
every time a joke bombs you chugged from
a box of wine
the main downside you gotta watch Jay
Leno FoxNews fans where you act every
time someone calls for Obama's birth
certificate was Obama born in Kenya
drink of vodka and ensure cocktail oh
and any time on Fox News a hot blonde
woman shows up on screen jerk-off so are
you drunk yet I am ha ha ha ha ha
what cocktail would you make for your
favorite show would it be a walking dead
colada a Sesame Street on the rocks a 60
Minutes sunrise
leave us the answer with the ingredients
in the comments below and the best one
gets a screen junkies t-shirt thanks for
watching I'm Mel Rudnick by bike